من جهته قال وزير الخارجيه الاسرائيلي الي
كهن انه اتفق مع قبرس على اقامه ممر بحري
بين قبرس وغزه على ان يكون باشراف ومراقبه
امنيه اسرائيليه وذلك من اجل ضمان انفصال
تام بين اسرائيل
وغزه عدت من قبرص في زياره خاطفه لخ ساعات
وقد اتفقت هناك على اقامه ممر بحري بين
قبرص وغزه على ان يكون باشراف ومراقبه
امنيه اسرائيليه وعلى نحو يمكننا من اغلاق
المعابر بين اسرائيل وغزه بشكل كامل ومن
اجل ان نضمن انفصالا تاما عن غزه قياده
التنسيق والارتباط في غزه سوف تتحول الى
متحف هذه مصلحه اسرائيل وهذا ما تقتضيه
المصلحه الاقليميه في لقائي مع وزير
الخارجيه القبرصي ومن خلال محادثات
اجريتها مع وزير الخارجيه البريطاني
اتفقنا على المنحى والتفاصيل
خ